NARRATOR: Imagine
life in 12,000 BC.
There are no societies, no
protections, no guarantees,
just small bands
of nomads wandering
the woods of Eurasia trying
to survive in a hostile world.
BRIAN FAGAN: These
people lived in very
predator-rich environments.
Lots of animals who
regarded humans as prey.
Fire was a deterrent.
It protected you
against predators.
[barking]
[non-english speech]
[barking and howling]
[crying]
NARRATOR: Imagine a
life so fragile, so
fraught with uncertainty,
only fire offers a chance
at survival moment to moment.
[animal sounds]
[non-english speech]
NARRATOR: This is the moment in
time when life for Homo sapiens
depends on this trick.
Take control of
the natural world
and create a weapon
to fight back.
Fire gave us the
chance at a future.
[non-english speech]
[growling]